[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro dieu de 7,8
société votre rendez vous hebdomadaire
pour débattre discuter et le fléchir sur
les sujets qui font l'actualité
alors c'est un rendez vous
incontournable pour près de 800 mille
candidats chaque année le baccalauréat
les épreuves 2021 débute le 17 juin
prochain mais après un an et demi de
crise sanitaire certains demandent un
aménagement voire une annulation alors
quel bac pour cette année 2021 on en
parle avec nos invités delphine romanée
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes co secrétaire
du snes fsu 78 le syndicat des
personnels enseignants d'éducation et
d'orientation des collèges et des lycées
et gabrielle renaud bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes responsable fédéral yvelines du
mouvement national lycéens alors le 5
mai dernier le ministre a fait des
annonces sur ce fameux baccalauréat ils
se refusent notamment à une annulation
totale des épreuves il est vrai de
renault est ce que le mouvement
nationaliste on lui avait fait la
demande d'annuler ce baccalauréat 2021
en contrôle continu un parfait un porte-
monde et une annulation de l'épreuve de
français à l'oral et une contre eux et
nous et a dûment toral alors le
baccalauréat c'est une épreuve décisive
pour la poursuite des études des
candidats tout ce qu'on veut lui faire
des études secondaires le sable est ce
qu aussi une annulation comme vous le
demandez pouvait être un autre obstacle
je pense pas parce que personne n'ait
prévenu pour l'oral de français menés
pour le grand oral on au courant de rien
aujourd'hui ils nous ont pas donné de
grandes vraie bataille sur
l'organisation du grand oral
les professeurs en tout cas sur mon lit
ces soirées perdu et les lycées en
corniche delphine roumanie ces deux
années scolaires ont été plutôt
mouvementée
les deux années du baccalauréat les
premières et les terminales s que du
côté des enseignants il ya aussi une
crainte de lycéens mal préparés c'est un
petit peu ce que j'ai
renault fut ressortir oui alors tout à
fait elle a parfaitement raison de dire
qu'il ya une certaine confusion qui est
lié aux nouvelles consignes qui ont été
données
ils sont pas très claires pour les
élèves mais en effet ne le sont pas pour
les profs après nous ce n'est ce là où
l'imposition d'y faire un petit peu de
celle des syndicats lycéens c'est que
nous nous sommes très attachés à un
diplôme qui va avoir une valeur
nationale et donc on va s'attacher à des
épreuves terminales nationale on pense
que le contrôle continu renforce les
inégalités
par contre là où on rejoint les lycéens
évidemment c'est qu' il fallait prendre
en compte le fait que la pandémie a
considérablement perturbé les
établissements et qu'il fallait
absolument faire des aménagements et
qu'on l'ait demandé c'est pour notre
part depuis le mois de novembre 2020
sauf que là on parle de ceux qui vont
passer le bac cette année ce sont des
jeunes qui ont aussi connu des épreuves
anticipées compliqué l année dernière
est ce que il n'y aurait pas une double
année difficile pour eux me d'amour mais
nous qui est la fleur nationale fac et 4
pouces qu'il est aussi symbolique très
important et que du fait de la pandémie
réparations très inégale certains disent
maintenant 2000 vosges d'autres pas du
tout il est plus ou moins de cours en
présentiel selon les établissements
donc il fallait évidemment évidemment
aménagé pour permettre aussi aux élèves
qui n'ont pas pu préparer l'examen dans
une condition de ne pas être pénalisés
par cette situation
gabriel où vous vous êtes en première
dans cette année est ce que cette année
mouvementée vous inquiète peut-être même
pour un bac 2022 oui parce qu'on n'a pas
eu par exemple laissé 3 c et l'année
prochaine on va avoir le troisième 3
c'est qu'on n'a pas eu cette année et
donc on n'est pas prêt parce qu'on ne
sait pas on n'a pas eu des preuves et on
sait pas à quoi s'attendre
alors je le disais tout à l'heure jean
michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
s'est exprimé le 5 mai dernier et
notamment à propos de la philosophique
et la première épreuve le 17 juin
prochain
je vous propose qu'on écoute le ministre
l'épreuve écrite de philosophie qui
concentre
beaucoup d'attention c'est normal cette
épreuve je sais que beaucoup d'entre eux
vont demander qu on la transforme en
contrôle continu
eh bien nous allons aller plus loin que
cette proposition puisque il y aura la
note de contrôle continu mais aussi
l'épreuve terminale qui aura lieu et
c'est la meilleure des deux notes qui
sera retenue c'est donc l'option la plus
belle un rayon de pauvres et gabrielle
renaud du côté de votre syndicat est ce
que c'est une annonce qui vous a à
rassurer non absolument pas parce que
c'est totalement insuffisant puisque le
problème c'est de réunir tous les
lycéens dans une même pièce close et
c'est vraiment de la mise en danger de
la vie des différents mais c'est
méprisant de re delphine roma dit son
sentiment que vous partagez alors
forcément de rapport à cette remarque
pour l'instant qu'il s'agisse du la
philosophie comme du grand oral des
épreuves de bac on n'a aucune garantie
qui aura un protocole sanitaire sérieux
qui sera mise en place
par ailleurs je crois que ce qui est
proposé par jean michel blanquer pour
tous constats l'épreuve de philosophie
ne résout pas les problèmes
d'abord c'est un manque de respect total
pour les élèves et les professeurs qui
ont préparé cette épreuve écrite et qui
maintenant perd une partie de son
d'enjeu elle va aussi conduire les
élèves à faire des choix stratégiques à
savoir est-ce qu'ils ont intérêt à
réellement préparé cette épreuve vous
tablez sur la base des preuves de notes
de contrôle continu qui finalement
pourrait les satisfaire
et puis troisième danger mais pas des
moindres en attribuant le droit au jury
de choisir entre la note de contrôle
continu et une note des preuves l'on
risque d'être de nouveau dans le chaos
qui avait déjà perturbé le bac 2010 9 et
le bac 2020 qui avait conduit à voile à
des modifications de note par les jurys
dans la plus grande opacité qui avait
semé le doute sur la qualité des notes
sur les pratiques assez douteuse de
certains établissements en particulier
des établissements un petit peu
prestigieux qui est chargé à tout prix à
valoriser leur candidat voilà tout ceci
n'est pas la hauteur de l'importance du
baccalauréat et du 2 du fait qu on a
besoin qu'il soit reconnu comme un
diplôme national sans aucun doute sur la
qualité des étudiants et des élèves
pardon ils reçoivent le contrôle continu
c'est aussi là elle est le sujet de
notre question de la semaine puisque
chaque semaine nous posons une question
aux téléspectateurs cette semaine
c'était bien sûr et ce qu'ils font
passer en contrôle continu
on va le voir à l'écran c'est le oui qui
a rassemblé le plus de votes mais pour
ceux qui ont voté non on met en avant
que le contrôle continu serait
discriminant pour les établissements les
candidats d'établissement pour moins
prestigieux c'est ce que vous disiez
avec delphine romani gabrielle renaud
justement est-ce que ce contrôle continu
pourrait mettre en difficulté des élèves
qui n'ont pas pu suivre correctement les
cours alors oui mais non que une épreuve
à la fin de l'année parce que ça revient
exactement au même ton chance ou si on
n'a pas fait tout le programme confié à
la fin d'année on a une épreuve sur un
texte où quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
étudié ce sera aussi pénalisant que si
on l'avait
par rapport aux contres continuer
sachant que cet inventif améliorable on
devoir en tout cas et que du coup c'est
eux
voilà alors le ministère de l'éducation
demande de faire aussi des comparaisons
par rapport aux sessions précédentes
pour la notation
le snes fsu met en avant que certaines
matières n'existait pas en plus les
années précédentes des filtres omani ça
renforce l'idée de difficultés à faire
passer ce baccalauréat
oui oui qui leur est dû à deux les têtes
monde est pressé en fait sa force
l'estey d'image d'occupation de
l'établissement de jeu suivant les
établissements et ça ne te prend pas en
compte le fait qu'un lycéen à titre
individuel peut avoir fait d'excellentes
performances et pro finale alors que
c'est il se trouve
scolarisé dans un établissement
jugez-moi moins prestigieux voilà les
pieds en aucun cas ça ne résout le
problème des énormes inégalités de
préparation contenu qu'ont connu les
élèves tout au long de cette année
scolaire c'est aussi ce qu'on reproche à
la tenue à toute force de grand oral je
pense qu on y viendra peut-être plus
tard dans cet entretien mais non
justement j'allais y venir parce que
celui là par contre ne sera pas modifiée
n'y aura pas de changement
toutefois jean michel blanquer indique
que les candidats pourront présenter un
message de leur professeur indiquant les
points de programme non étudiants en
enseignement de spécialité
ça vous semble réalisable ce type d'
annonce delphine rovani non et puis à
l'ordre par ailleurs ça résout pas les
problèmes de fond à nourrice nas on a
été très opposés à ce grand oral de
puits depuis qu'il a été mise en place
parce que par sa nature cette épreuve
est profondément inégalitaire et c'est
justement une épreuve qui a la
particularité de se souder mois sur les
connaissances qu'ils ont été acquises
par le candidat que pour sur sa manière
de les présenter et donc ça c'est c'est
quelque chose qui socialement marqué
très socialement marquez qui aurait sont
ces êtres qui était censé avoir été
préparé et qui n'a pas
et préparez donc le fait d'enlever
certaines parties du programme ça ça
fait face à un problème de l'acquisition
des connaissances mais finalement ce
n'est pas le fond du problème puisque
nous ce qui nous pose problème c'est
cette épreuve qui revêt lé qui repose
sur l'évaluation de compétences et ses
compétences à elles n'ont pas été
travaillée pendant l'année et par
ailleurs comme je le disais elles sont
profondément influencé par le profil
l'origine sociale le profil sociologique
de l'élève gabrielle renaud c'est un
sentiment qui est partagé par votre
mouvement votre syndicat les professeurs
n'ont pas nécessairement pu accompagner
tous leurs élèves comme exactement ça
dépend vraiment de regrets et élève ces
enfants qui ment à ses 10 à mon sens du
mépris de la part de jean michel
blanckaert a abrogé parce qu'il n'a pas
eu tous les mêmes mots d'enseignement et
on est tous un petit peu alors vous
l'avez vite faits évoqués tout à l'heure
à gabrielle renaud la condition
sanitaire autre que l'aspect seulement
des enseignements il ya des lycées qui
ont fait le choix d' isoler les
candidats une semaine avant le bac ne
pas les faire venir au lycée c'est
d'avoir une sorte de confinement
gabrielle renaud vous vous partagez
cette idée vous dites que vous ça
devrait être mis en place dans tous les
lycées
je pense que c'est impossible à être à
mettre en place parce qu'on peut pas
obliger les élèves à rester à la maison
on aura qu aucune preuve qu'ils sont
vraiment dresser contre ces mêmes chez
eux et c'est pas aux élèves de respecter
une sorte de quarantaine youtube une
semaine mais aux établissements de
prendre en compte le fait qu'il ait une
possibilité de transmission du virus et
donc de mettre en place des appareils
qui peuvent par exemple détecter le co2
ou une altération des fenêtres mais
quand il faut se serait inefficace parce
que la transmission toujours être là
donc le plus impressionné encore une
fois d'annuler les épreuves
delphine roumanie est ce que vous savez
si des établissements il faisait noir
ont fait le choix de d'isoler les élèves
les lycéens les candidats alors isolé je
ne sais pas s'il m'a effectivement on
commence par des premiers établissements
qui ont fait le choix de fermer plus tôt
non pas pour qu'il s'isole à la maison
ça effectivement comme le disait gabriel
on ne pourra jamais à le vérifier mais
par contre pour éviter effectivement td
kloster qui se forme à quelques semaines
des épreuves et que toute la classe soit
empêchée de passer le baccalauréat
ça semble être une des mesures de bon
sens qui est tout à fait inverse de ce
qui s'est produit pour les élèves les
épreuves de bts ou au contraire menaces
et des collègues des élèves d'avoir un
0/6 ne se présentait pas aux épreuves ce
qui a conduit hier un certain nombre de
candidats à se présenter aux épreuves
qui ont eu lieu au mois d'avril alors
qu'ils étaient contaminés par le colis
de 19 donc ça ça nous paraît une méthode
de bon sens mais en effet il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin sur les protocoles
sanitaires l'avenir des épreuves sans se
préoccuper de la manière dont vont se
dérouler d'un point de vue pratique se
comparer tout à fait irresponsable
donc on est à un mois maintenant des
premières épreuves en vous entendant
c'est encore le flou delphine revenus
c'est encore le flou il ya en fait
sortes d'enjeux politiques à vouloir à
toute force maintenir les épreuves le
grand oral qui est qui devenu vraiment
l'emblème du bac blanc caire est un
espèce de totem comme ça qu'on cherche à
préserver à tout prix
donc ça vraiment ça semble être la
priorité du ministère langer politique
montrer qu'il a mené la réforme à son
terme
une fois encore les annonces elles se
sont faites de manière tardive de
manière précipitée désorganisée et donc
finalement on met en difficulté les
élèves on met en difficulté les familles
qui elles aussi ressentent le stress et
enfin mais aussi en difficulté les
enseignants qui maintenant doivent
préparer au coût de culte pour les aider
les élèves à des épreuves qui sont mal
anticipée va le préparer
je vais terminer avec vous gabriel
renoux quel va être le mois à venir pour
le mouvement national lycéens vous allez
appeler à bloquer à faire des mouvements
à manifester
est ce que vous allez agir sur le
terrain oui on continuer blocus jusqu'à
ce que j'en ai pour l'anc et reprennent
deux pour être décision aujourd'hui on a
près de 800 lycées bloqués depuis le
début de la mobilisation c'est énorme et
on compte continuer jusqu'à ce qu'il y
ait de vrais résultats de la part du
ministère merci
toutes les deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation 7,8 société est maintenant
terminée on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau autant
d'échangés prenait d'ici là prenez soin
de vous
[Musique]